[Applause]
hey guys it's me Debbie
today we're talking about that tiny
little pill they're poisoning your body
with every day just to avoid the burden
of having a baby totally not worth the
toxins people's family planning it's
really none of your business Deb hey
people's bodies are totally my business
the pill screws up everything we're
talking about blood clots stroke
depression even lost libido oh yeah plus
worst of all you can gain a bunch of
weight not happening here whoa whoa
there Deb let's ease into that one
talking about contraceptives is both
controversial and really complicated now
not to bore you with a history lesson
but in the past birth control pills
contain really high doses of estrogen
which was what was responsible for the
significant weight gain and some of the
other side effects scientists have now
done extensive research and they
developed new birth control pills with
far fewer side effects well I'm not
convinced it's the hormones girl
estrogen progesterone I don't trust them
I mean forget about your diet it's the
artificial toxic hormones that's making
us ladies fat I agree
hormones can be a little sketchy and
sometimes they have a mind of their own
but let's break this down for you for a
moment
so today at most birth control pills are
either in combination form so they
contain both estrogen and progesterone
or their progesterone only in a 2014
Cochrane review looking at the
combination birth control four studies
found no significant difference in
weight gain the largest difference found
was about four pounds into 12 months aha
that's still a gain of sweet poundage
kill the pill kill the pill till the
pill oh not so fast
interestingly we hypothesize that the
estrogen would cause the weight gain
however in the research the group of
women who gained the weight were
actually the ones with less estrogen on
top of that another study found that
women on the pill had a 5 percent higher
metabolic rate so then it's the
progesterone that's the real culprit so
a comprehensive review of 60
studies looking at the progesterone only
pill fail not the weight gain was
honestly pretty modest we're looking at
like 5 pounds over 12 months now as a
woman I can totally empathize that
sometimes five pounds seems like a lot
it seems like a lot but statistically
it's not really that significant there
is however one form of progesterone only
birth control that is linked to weight
gain and that's the depo method Roxy the
depo MEC Roxy med Rox
Roxy progesterone acetate right like
that it's called the depo
medroxyprogesterone acetate it's called
a depo-provera shot you guys know what
I'm talking about right DP DP up in the
hooves you know I know I had a lot of
friends on the shot when I was in high
school and even I remember the horror
stories one study found an average of
about 10 pounds of weight gain in the
first year of use now when you're 16 and
you're 120 pounds soaking wet
I get that probably feels like a lot I
still don't trust any of them I mean all
of my friends agree with me some of my
friends said that the pill increase her
appetite and they ate all the things at
once
another friend told me that she bloated
up like a blimp some studies have looked
at appetite changes while on the pill
and they actually found that most
changes in appetite were largely
perception based having said that they
didn't really test actual caloric intake
so sadly this is not the best quality
research theoretically high doses of
estrogen do cause some water attention
however most of the pills out there
today are super low dose estrogen
research has actually concluded that the
pill doesn't actually cause significant
bloating but if you're worried about
bloating and you're really sensitive to
small changes definitely speak to your
doctor about getting the lowest dose
estrogen birth control pill that will
work for you all right so maybe there
are other reasons why we're gaining
weight but I just had an article that
said that birth control was linked with
depression explain that one Abby we are
in sync today dad because I just read
the exact same article a recently
published Danish study followed a
million women
for six years and they found a
significant correlation between birth
control pill and clinical depression
they found that women who are taking any
kind of form of birth control pills were
significantly more likely to be
prescribed antidepressants hey if we
know this why are we doing anything
about it I mean it's not something that
you should be that surprised about Deb
this is not the first time to find a
significant correlation between hormonal
birth control and mood changes
historically women's health was not
exactly at the forefront of the medical
community or even the political
community up until the early part of the
20th century birth control was actually
illegal forcing women into a ton of the
unplanned pregnancies and forcing them
to risk their lives with hysterectomies
and unsafe abortion this is a systemic
issue here dead well you know I'm no
feminist but I bet you if men had to
take the pill they wouldn't have all
these side-effects that we have to deal
with right it's funny you say that Deb
because there's actually being some
serious advances with the male pills but
as expected there's been some serious
backlash these pills contain both
progesterone and testosterone so the
largest study of 320 men found there
were a few side effects so research on
that is still in the making
also big pharma does not seem to be
rushing to fund the stuff either classic
patriarchal medicine it is a man's world
there Debbie even ironically with
reproductive rights I hear your sister
finally something we can agree on
ultimately we may be moving forward in
women's health but there's still a lot
that needs to be done
that being said studies like the Danish
study are finally giving women a voice
and more control over the health because
ultimately knowledge is power and we
have a right to know what we're
ingesting the effect that birth control
has on our weight doesn't
however I can totally empathize that
sometimes even five counts can seem like
a lot at the end of the day it's all a
risk of benefit analysis and you've
really got to decide what side effects
you're willing to tolerate for the
benefit of avoiding an unwanted
pregnancy remember to always speak to
your doctor about your concerns and
continue to read up on all the new
studies we're really just scratching the
surface understanding all the ways that
our hormones can affect our health
finally this is the time to really
paying attention to your government's
role in your reproductive health don't
be silent so guys I hope you enjoyed
this video be sure to give it the thumbs
up leave me a comment below with some of
your questions what are your thoughts on
birth control
did you guys gain weight on it did you
not subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen
[Music]